et pour en parler nous sommes avec
claude blanchemaison expert en relations
internationales bonsoir claude
blanchemaison merci d'être avec nous et
l'albula snowboardeuse donc peut-elle
rapprocher la chine et les états unis
comme elle le souhaiterait ou au
contraire les éloigner encore un petit
peu plus je ne crois pas que cet épisode
constr contribuer à rapprocher vraiment
les états unis de la chine l'hostilité
entre les familles et la chine et elle
est bien connue la chine est en train de
poursuivre sa croissance économique pour
un jour prendre la place les états unis
et devenir la puissance numéro un dans
le monde donc il ya une rivalité qui
fait qu'elle est beaucoup plus important
pour les états unis de contenir la chine
par tous les moyens
simplement ce qui se passe c'est que
hélène goût est né à san francisco d'un
père américain et d'une mère chinoise
qui est d'ailleurs une femme d'affaires
chinoise aux états unis et que jusqu'à
il ya trois ans elle faisait ses
compétitions sous le drapeau américain
et puis il ya trois ans elle a choisi
avec les organisations sportives de le
faire sous drapeau chinois la république
populaire de cl c'est son choix et et ça
ne contribue pas véritablement à au
rapprochement entre les etats-unis et la
chine peut être même sacré des frictions
additionnel parce que le public
américain peut se demander pourquoi elle
a déserté les états unis pour se placer
sous le drapeau chinois alors d'autant
plus qu'il ya cette fameuse loi sur la
citoyenneté en chine qui n'autorise pas
la double nationalité alors que
va-t-elle faire renoncer à la
nationalité américaine mais à 18 ans
elle a beaucoup de sagesse puisqu'elle a
dit lorsque je suis aux états unis et je
me sens pleinement américaine lorsque je
suis en chine je me sens pleinement
chinoise c'est l'explication alors je
pense que elle est aujourd'hui une très
grande vedette de les jeux olympiques
d'hiver de pékin est par conséquent
pékin a bien vu l'intérêt qu'il y avait
à la cultiver et à la faire concourir
sous le drapeau chinois et que les
chinois sont des pragmatiques
s'il faut lui donner la nationalité
chinoise au moins sur le plan sportif
parce que ça ne veut pas dire qu'elle
lave sur tous les plans eh bien on lui
donne la nationalité chinoise pour
gagner les compétitions et rapporter des
médailles d'or de son côté n'est ce pas
avant tout aussi une décision peut-être
financière totalement la maman et femme
d'affaires chinoise aux états unis et
tous les médias expliquent que les
grands sponsors notamment les maisons de
luxe lvmh avec eux il ya cycle est
quelques autres la banque de chine
considère qu'
il n' goût et est un très très bon un
très bon investissement je crois que
l'année dernière en 2021 elle a pu
recueillir environ 30 millions de
dollars au titre des sponsors de deux
compétitions qui n'étaient pas les jeux
olympiques alors qu'est ce que ça va
être pour les jeux olympiques donc là
dessus en effet il n'y a pas de
questions toutes les grandes entreprises
considèrent que le marché chinois est
tellement énorme que ça vaut la peine
d'investir dans cette image dans hélène
goût est envoyée derrière vous que
beaucoup de sponsors ont déjà succombé à
la tentation effectivement d'utiliser
jeunes en bout en mannequin alors sur le
volet diplomatique
clos blanchemaison pour cette édition
des jeux de nombreux pays on le sait
comme les états unis le royaume uni
l'australie le canada ou le japon ont
décidé de n'envoyer aucun responsable
politique dans le but de dénoncer les
atteintes aux droits de l'homme et la
répression envers les minorités
musulmanes des ouigours legio toujours
décidément à l'arrière-plan de la
diplomatie mais c'est pas nous ça a
toujours été le cas en 1936 la question
s'est posée pour les jo de berlin qui
était
organisée pour célébrer le pouvoir des
clercs
ensuite il ya eu d'autres gio qui ont
été boycottées en russie aux etats-unis
et ailleurs mais c'est un vrai code
politique tant qu'il s'agit d'un boycott
politique c'était un symbole dans le
fond il n'y a pas de délégations
officielles gouvernementales
ça n'est pas très grave encore que la
france avait décidé d'envoyer sa
ministre des sports qui je prend
malheureusement été déclarée positive au
que vie de 19 et n'a pas pu s'y rendre
mais politiquement le symbole était
qu'il y aurait eu un membre du
gouvernement français présents à
l'ouverture des jeux alors je crois pour
le reste est bien et ce qui est
important c'est que les sportifs
puissent faire la compétition qui serait
très grave c'est qu'on empêche des
sportifs d'aller concourir à des jeux
sous prétexte de devises vie politique
merci beaucoup claude blanche raison
d'avoir été avec nous et les